are we sending a message are we sending
a purposeful message is there a machine
that is creating a frequency and sending
that out into the universe right now
from our planet yeah we've done a couple
of stunts think about it if you transmit
whatever your message is however you
want to to create it and transmit it if
you transmit it for five minutes
that message is going to go past your
intended target in five minutes right
it's only going to be visible for five
minutes and so at the Target somebody
would have to be looking
at you with exactly the right tools at
exactly the right time so transmission
for me has always been a long-term
project
and I don't think we're grown up enough
to take that on right I think that um
if you start to transmit you have to
continue
uh and and do it for time scales that we
humans are not used to dealing with you
know tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years
so you asked if we're transmitting as I
said there were these stunts limited
time but we are also
um
leaking radiation right we have
broadcast transmitters that are leaking
off the planet and of course they're not
very strong because they're intended to
illuminate the next County not the next
star system but with some sufficiently
advanced technology it might be
detectable we are modifying our
atmosphere because of biology and
Technology
so the components in our atmosphere are
well first of all it's highly oxygenated
due to life due to photosynthesis and
the um
some of the trace gases are remnants of
Technology
um
that's our technology yeah our
technology that could be seen at a
distance
um
so we are detectable by a sufficiently
advanced
um civilization is it impressive to you
how far we've come in a short amount of
time as humans I think it's impressive I
think when you think of well my mother
died when she was 98. when I think of
the changes that she saw in her lifetime
it's pretty astonishing and
people young people now are all about
change and nothing stays the same
and they are used to the fact and they
begin to expect and require and
anticipate that things will change in
particular their devices will get faster
or more capable or yeah they will have
other ways of communicating with their
um with their peers
and they will be able to access
information in ways that we never could
before
and
so their lives will be different as a
result is there anybody uh is there
someone young it makes me think of just
asking the question if there's somebody
very young with a perhaps completely New
Perspective that's introduced an idea
um
into the realm of
um
the universe and what's out there that
has been Monumental in taking steps
forward and discovering more
well I think the answer to that
inevitably is yes if you limit it to
what we've been doing
yeah there are um
there's receiver technology
that's new so how you build whatever it
is that takes
the energy that's collected by a
reflector a telescope of some kind
and transforms it into
a voltage as a function of time and then
transforms that into a frequency pattern
those technologies have changed
um their things
just just different kinds of things that
we we didn't have before yeah you can do
and and again often young people
who are clever and come at this from a
different direction and they say oh I
have this
Gadget hmm
and and maybe if I take a look at your
data
that Gadget can tell me something that
you haven't been looking for
so yes and I I hopefully more of that
will happen
um you had mentioned time and
um I was fascinated by the idea of this
time space reality time and space and
what is it and does it exist in in the
universe and and is time and space the
way that we know it is that is that
local is that a is that a local
phenomenon here on the planet well there
have been some experiments again in a
Quantum physicists love to talk about
this stuff and and try and do
experiments to the best of my knowledge
they have not found any locality
that that time and space and the physics
that connect them
do seem to be Universal
and not limited to our
our local neighborhood
how does that explain
quantum entanglement then
well that's certainly a non-local
phenomenon I mean it starts out locally
but then you can separate the the
entangled
particles or states by large distances
and yet they instantaneously respond to
a perturbation in one in one place at a
great distance so that's definitely not
local
how does it explain it I don't know I
mean I I think quantum entanglement is
something that lots of smart people are
scratching their heads over spooky
things happening at a distance right is
that what Einstein called it yep he did
and he didn't believe it
but he acknowledged it yeah well but he
he fundamentally did not think that this
um was
up
a part of the structure of the Universe
I find it fascinating that there's
Newtonian physics and then there's
quantum physics or quantum mechanics and
they don't Jive yet they're both
essentially
been proven to be true yeah it's scale
right
so at
at the earliest times and smallest
scales
we cannot yet make gravity
and quantum mechanics play nice together
right so you can't as you try and go
back and describe the structure of the
universe at
smaller scales and earlier times
we see a breakdown we we can't carry it
all the way back to the singularity
and that's just because there's more for
us to learn about the physics of the
universe
do you believe that there is a theory of
everything
yes I do I I do believe that there is
some fundamental
underlying structure
and reason and physics
that will ultimately explain everything
but I think at the moment we're more
like
um when early astronomers were trying to
explain the
um
the orbits of the planets
by using perfect circles right they
weren't allowing for ellipses
and they kept adding complexities so
they added another layer of circles
epicycles and that kind of thing I think
we might be
somewhat in that state in the sense that
we haven't figured out what the ellipse
is that
um helps us
to to get to a theory of everything what
will be the ripple effect of that if you
can if there could be a way to quantify
from scale the largest to the smallest
things
what happens next well it would really
have a big effect on the stock market
I'll say
in what way if we get to be
a multi
body or multi-planetary
civilization how are we going to deal
with
making a transaction in one place
when there are all these different time
delays from those who want to make the
transactions being at different
distances away
um
at one point
oh I can't remember who it was someone
uh suggested that uh
neutrinos might help solve this problem
if we could in fact build neutrino
detectors because they would be able to
take the shortest paths and go right
through everything to get oh it's a
neutrino a neutrino is a fundamental
particle
massless and
it's produced in
high energy collisions
of of particles
and it um
it was very hard to prove the existence
of an neutrino but basically it doesn't
interact with anything so it goes
through land without ever seeing the
lead atoms right
um and so that wow perhaps neutrinos
could
help solve this transactional difficulty
because they could go straight through
everything and how you trap them that
that of course is the question
um and they wouldn't have to follow the
space-time paths that that photons
take
[Music]